>> Tucker: THERE'S AN AWFUL
LOT OF NEWS TODAY ALONG WITH THE
BOTTOM OF THE IG REPORT, TODAY
ALSO BROUGHT A ROUND OF
IMPEACHMENT HEARINGS IN THE
HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
DURING THOSE HEARINGS,
CONGRESSMAN MATT GAETZ OF
FLORIDA GOT INTO IT WITH THE
CHAIRMAN FROM NEW YORK'S JERRY
NADLER OVER THE REFUSAL TO MAKE
ADAM SCHIFF TESTIFY BEFORE THE
COMMUNITY.
HERE'S HOW IT WENT.
>> THE IMPLICATION IS WE WANT
SCHIFF IN THAT CHAIR, NOT YOU.
THE PERSON WHO WROTE THE REPORT
SHOULD COME AND PRESENT IT AND
YOU WHEN ELECTED BY ANYBODY AND
YOU'RE GIVING THAT TESTIMONY IN
PLACE OF THE CHAIRMAN.
I HOPE THAT CLEARS UP THE
IMPLICATION.
>> HE CANNOT SIMPLY YELL OUT AND
DISRUPT THE COMMITTEE!
>> Tucker: NOT ALLOWED TO MAKE
RATIONAL POINTS ON THE HILL.
CONGRESSMAN MATT GAETZ OF
FLORIDA JOINS US.
LOOKS LIKE YOU CLEARED UP THAT
IMPLICATION.
>> I MAY NOT BE ON JERROLD
NADLER'S CHRISTMAS LIST ANYMORE.
IF HE BELIEVES THAT THE
HE SHOULD TAKE QUESTIONS BASED
ON HIS BIAS, HIS CONTACT WITH
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER, AND ANYTHING
HE WAS DOING OUTSIDE THE BOUNDS
OF THE LAW.
INSTEAD, IT WAS DAY CURED DONOR
TO WORK TODAY, WHERE SOME OF THE
LEFT'S BIG DONORS WERE ABLE TO
COME IN AND ASKED OTHER
QUESTIONS BUT IT'S THIS
DYSTOPIAN REALITY WHERE I'M
WATCHING ONE DEMOCRAT DONOR
ASKED QUESTIONS OF ANOTHER
DEMOCRAT DONOR ABOUT ISSUES THAT
WE COULD ALL READ ABOUT BUT THEY
JUST WANT TO GIVE THEIR HOT
TAKES.
>> Tucker: SUCH A NICE
DESCRIPTION.
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER.
ARE WE EVER GOING TO HAVE PUBLIC
CONFIRMATION OF THIS PERSON THE
PROSPEROUS IDENTITY AND DOESN'T
MATTER?
>> DOES
IT DEPENDS ON THE DAY.
ADAM SCHIFF SAID THE ONLY WAY TO
RESOLVE THE DISPUTE IS TO HEAR
FROM THE WHISTLE-BLOWER AND
LATER WHEN THE WHISTLE-BLOWER'S
POTENTIAL CONNECTIONS TO MEMBERS
OF ADAM SCHIFF'S COMMITTEE OR
POTENTIAL CONVENTIONS TO
CAMPAIGNS STARTED LEAKING OUT TO
PUBLIC REPORTING, THEY DIDN'T
WANT TO HEAR FROM THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER ANYMORE.
>> Tucker: WITHOUT USING HIS
NAME ARE YOU SATISFIED THAT THE
PERSON IDENTIFIED AS A
WHISTLE-BLOWER HAS BEEN --
>> THE ONLY PERSON WHO KNOWS WHO
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER IS AS ADAM
SCHIFF.
>> Tucker: WILL BE TALKING
WITH KEN STARR ABOUT TODAY'S
IMPEACHMENT HEARINGS BUT WE WANT
TO GET TO THIS.
WANT TO ASK ABOUT THE
CONGRESSMAN AT THE NAVAL AIR
STATION AT PENSACOLA.
IT WAS COMMITTED BY A SAUDI
NAVAL OFFICER.
THE QUESTION, OBVIOUS ONE, IS IT
TIME BASED ON THIS ANOTHER FACT
TO REEVALUATE OUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH SAUDI ARABIA?
>> THE FIRST THING WE NEED TO DO
IS TO JOIN GOVERNOR DeSANTIS'
CALL TO THE KINGDOM TO STEP OVER
THE VICTIM.
I WILL CALL FOR THE MEDIAN
SUSPENSION FOR THE PROGRAM WILL
BE BRING SAUDIS HERE TO THE
UNITED STATES WITHOUT
SUFFICIENT VETTING TO STOP
LIVING LIKE THIS.
WE PUT OURSELVES AT RISK.
AND ABSOLUTELY WE NEED TO
SUPPORT THE FBI'S INVESTIGATION
AND NOT ALLOW ANYTHING TO IMPAIR
IT.
AT SOME POINT, WE'VE GOT TO LOOK
AT HIS RELIGION MORE BROADLY,
TUCKER, AND WONDER HOW MUCH FROM
SAUDI ARABIA ARE WE WILLING TO
TAKE?
>> ESPECIALLY BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE A DEFINITIVE ANSWER ABOUT
THE SAUDIS ROLE IN 9/11.
>> YOU DON'T THINK IT'S
DEFINITIVE?
I THINK IT'S DEFINITIVE THAT
MEMBERS OF THE SAUDI GOVERNMENT
WERE SUPPORTING SOME OF THE
GROUND EFFORTS IN 9/11.
>> Tucker: SOME DETAILS REMAIN
HIDDEN FROM THE U.S. GOVERNMENT.
WHAT'S BAFFLING TO ME IS HOW
THERE IS RESENTED BY PART OF
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT BY ONE OF THE
CREEPIEST, MOST REPRESSIVE
NATIONS AND EARTH.
WHY DO WE DO THIS QUESTION MARKS
BECAUSE THEY TRADE IN OIL ON THE
U.S. DOLLAR.
IF YOU WANT TO HAVE TRUTH TALK,
WE NEED THEM SELLING OIL ON THE
U.S. DOLLAR IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN
THE DOMINANCE OF THE DOLLAR AND
MAKE OUR SANCTIONS EFFECTIVE
ELSEWHERE IN THE WORLD AMONGST
OIL-PRODUCING NATIONS.
THAT IS NOT A REASON TO TURN A
BLIND EYE TO SAUDI POTENTIAL OF
INVOLVEMENT IN 9/11, THE
SHOOTING IN PENSACOLA.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THEIR WAR IN
YEMEN, SAUDI ARABIA IS ENGAGED
IN ALL KINDS OF TERRIBLE
ATROCIOUS
>> Tucker: IF THOSE PEOPLE WHO
COLLUDED IN 9/11 WERE IRANIAN,
THERE WOULD BE TROOPS ON THE
GROUND AND I WOULD SUPPORT IT.